das ist ja ein schäfer unserer politik
chef die hoffnung die stirbt zuletzt wir
fragen uns gibt es noch die chance auf
einen laschet wunder und diese frage
mich direkt jahren schönen guten morgen
wenn ich weiter reich und morgen und
beim thema experimente oder keine
experimente da sind wir natürlich direkt
bei armin laschet an armin laschet
versuchte es auch in diesem wahlkampf
ohne experimente er versucht das gleiche
zu machen die 2017 als er dann am ende
doch sehr überraschend ministerpräsident
von nordrhein-westfalen geworden es gibt
mehrere dinge die fast ähnlich sind also
über die schlechten umfragewerte von
damals 2 17 bis kurz vor der wahl
brauchen wir nicht zu sprechen die sind
glaube ich noch jedem im gedächtnis aber
er versucht es zum beispiel auch mit
angela merkel wieder wird sie also im
wahlkampf jetzt wie auch 2017 mehrmals
in seine wahlveranstaltung noch mal dazu
laden mutmaßlich vielleicht sogar wieder
einen tag vor der bundestagswahl nach
aachen holen genauso war es 2017 auch er
hat friedrich merz die cdu ikone in
seinem wahlkampfteam genau wie 2017
heute um 10 uhr gibt es im gemeinsamen
auftritt auch hier zu sehen bei bild
live und er hat auch wie 2017 sich offen
gehalten als juniorpartner in eine spd
geführte regierung einzutreten als es
gibt viele viele parallelen die dafür
sprechen dass armin laschet keine
experimente macht und genau wie 217
diesen wahlkampf jetzt auf der
zielgeraden doch noch gewinnen lore
kraft war ja damals die amtierende
ministerpräsidentin und wirklich jeder
dachte die ist nicht zu schlagen absolut
richtig und wenn man sich wehrte
anschaut von vor zwei wochen vor der
landtagswahl damals in nordrhein
westfalen also von ende april von anfang
mai dann gibt es zum beispiel bei der
frage wenn armin laschet oder hannelore
kraft die damalige ministerpräsidentin
direkt gewählt werden oder einen
massiven unterschied hannelore kraft
total beliebt zu dem zeitpunkt noch lag
20 prozentpunkte vor armin laschet
ähnlich ist das jetzt ja im verhältnis
olaf scholz zu armin laschet auch aber
dann legt er einen fulminanten endspurt
hin lastminute laschet ist es gewesen
und darauf setzt er diesmal auch brauche
noch mehr zutaten reicht es auf die
unterstützung der kanzlerin zu setzen
auch merz jetzt nochmal heute ins spiel
zu holen oder glaubst du er braucht noch
mehr zutaten da wird dieser turbo jetzt
am ende auch wirklich findet also es
gibt ja eine erste umfrage die hoffnung
macht über wochen ist armin laschet und
ist die cdu ja abgestürzt in den
umfragen bis auf 19 prozent also
historisches tief und gestern gab es
eine umfrage die mut macht zumindest im
lager der union
21 prozent dass sie einen sprung um zwei
punkte und das könnte genau diese
trendwende einläuten auf die armin
laschet setzt und die er schon mal
erlebt hat stichwort keine experimente
nämlich im jahr 2017
[Musik]